when creating business presentations it
easily happens that the slides that you
come up with
look like walls of text when everything
you write might be perfectly
fine and correct just the look of it is
boring it's not
interesting and for sure this is not
what you want for your professional
presentations so when i worked at
mckinsey we often like to talk about the
look
and feel of a slide so independent of
the content what is the look and feel of
what you are creating so in today's
video
i am talking about how you can improve
the look and feel of your presentation
documents by
using icons so welcome to another coffee
break here on my channel firm learning
my name is heinrich and here on my
channel i want to help you to become
successful
in the first years of your career i want
to start by say thank you to simple
slides the sponsor of today's video
simple slide is a service offering slide
templates and infographics i use the
service myself and can very much
recommend it but more about that later
in the video so thank you for joining me
in today's video grab yourself a cup of
coffee as always today i'm just sticking
to my water because it's already quite
late in germany but i hope that you are
having a great time so let's now look
into a situation which i am facing
pretty much
every single day and this is i have a
page like this
so this is a typical text page in this
example there is a company who looks
into expanding into new geographies in
new sectors and now here you're
summarizing all the opportunities that
this company might have so for instance
geographic expansion to new countries or
sector expansion into new sectors
now why all of this might be completely
accurate what i write here somehow this
page seems kind of dull it seems kind of
boring it's pretty much
just a wall of text and while it's okay
to have some pages like that in your
document
you do want to make sure that not every
page looks like this
and indeed a simple way that you can do
to improve the look and feel of a slide
like this
is to use some icons to add some icons
to your page
and if you work for a large consulting
firm probably you have
libraries of icons libraries of little
infographics to your disposal that you
can use but now for the average
joe and probably also for somebody not
working in these typical consulting
firms
the access to these kind of slide
libraries is much more restricted
most companies just do not have
something like this off the shave
of course what you can do is to go on
google and google for some icons there
in the picture search
but here of course the issue is that
most of the material is copyright
protected so you cannot just use it for
professional context and just don't want
to use it in your business presentations
even if you're an employee because
otherwise you might risk that your
employer gets into serious trouble if
you use these copyright protected
pictures
so thankfully there's a service that i
also use myself for my presentations and
this
service is called simple slides simple
slides is a library of slide templates
and infographics that are at your
disposal and if you get simple slides
you can use all the material for
whatever application you want so for
business and commercial purposes as well
they have over 10
000 slides and infographics at your
disposal and the library is constantly
being updated
also it doesn't matter what software you
use so whether you use powerpoint google
slides or keynote they have material for
all these software packages so you
should be covered in either way simple
slides offers three different tiers
personally have the premium access which
gives me access to all of their
materials and all of future updates as
well
and yes this is a lifetime access so for
a one-off payment you can use it your
whole life this is how it looks like on
the back end once you've opened an
account and then here on access slides
you have access to the search bar
where you can look for whatever you want
so if we type in
strategy you get different results for
that if we type in marketing you get
different results for that and all of
these are search results leading to
slide packages where then you can access
many different infographics and slides
that fit the individual theme but now
i'm looking for icons because i want to
add some icons to the powerpoint
presentation
so let's search for icons and you can
directly see that several search results
are popping up so let's just start by
looking into the vector icons and here
they now offer a package of all kinds of
vector icons that you can use for your
presentation so if we now download here
the powerpoint version
it pretty much looks like this now i've
opened it here for you guys
this is now the package that you get so
about 14 pages full of different icon
sets that you can use for your
presentation
including also some world maps which you
can use and then also use individual
countries out of it
so let's now go back and prepare the
page for adding some icons so i'm
duplicating the page now let's first
make some space our goal is to add the
icons to the left here
so let's make this a little bit smaller
let's move this
to the right and now we have some space
to add some icons here to the left so
first we have here two countries
germany and france and here of course
now it would make sense to get
some country icons so here now you can
click in and select
germany to then get the icon for germany
now it's of course pretty gray so let's
color it in such a nice dark blue and we
have the first one
now let's add the equivalent for france
let's insert it this way
color it now we have an icon for france
let's make this a little bit smaller
maybe
now it looks good to me let's properly
align it
very nice now data analysis so let's
just look for what we could use for data
analysis
probably something like this makes a lot
of sense let's color it as well
now for express services probably
something like a delivery service or
parcels or something like that this one
here looks good to me let's insert it as
well let's color it
probably not also another advantage of
these types of infographics that you see
here is that they are vector graphics so
this means that it doesn't matter
how big they are whatever the sizes that
you need
they will never look out of resolution
right because the resolution
automatically scales which is of course
very comfortable when working with them
in different sizes
but let's make this smaller now here we
go and let's now add this to the page
as way next mining services so probably
something with
workshop tools would look nice for
instance something like this
let's add it let's color it let's insert
it
and here we go so now we have it we have
icons included in the page and i hope
that you agree that now this looks a bit
more interesting
it's a bit nicer to look at your
presentation looks a bit
less dull if you do this so in general
whenever you have some distinct
elements of your page that you talk
about distinct buckets of things this is
usually always an opportunity to include
some icons to make it a little bit more
visually stimulating what you should
avoid though what i see some people do
is to only show the icons without the
explaining
text so pretty much to something like
this just here the text and the icons
this is something i cannot recommend you
to do because the problem is that icons
often are not
that self-explanatory it often takes
quite some time and mental energy to
interpret what exactly this or this or
this
means and easily different people will
have different opinions on that the only
very few icons which are universally and
interculturally accepted and recognized
to use this very carefully use icons
only to add to an existing name but do
not
only rely on the power of icons so when
should you and when should you not use
icons in your professional business
presentations and my general
recommendation would be to use them but
to use them sparsely
so often a good way to use them is if
you have some elements
some opportunities some levers some
other buckets of things you
have in your presentation that repeat
throughout the slide deck because this
way you can establish some icons in the
beginning on some structure pages and to
help the reader to make some connections
among the different pages due to the
repeating icons that you use so
applications like this in my opinion
make a lot of sense because they improve
the look and feel of the pages and
they also have a valuable benefit for
the reader what you should avoid is
completely spamming your presentation
with icons
of course in these business
presentations on almost every page you
will have an opportunity to in theory
add a couple of icons to them but if you
add icons to everything they just become
meaningless and at some point it also
looks
very repetitive and also to some extent
unprofessional and childish if you do
that
try to convey meaning via the icons try
to use them as a true value add for the
reader
this is the sweet spot that you should
really look out for when using icons in
your presentations i hope this was
insightful if you have any questions
leave me a comment below in the comment
section and i will do my very best to
answer
every single one if you want to learn
more about simple slides i added a link
to their servers below in the video
description
there you can sign up what i also very
much like about the service is that it's
not one of these
monthly subscriptions where you end up
paying for it forever but it's rather a
one-time
fee so if you took any value out of this
video at all please hit the like button
for the youtube algorithm and also
subscribe to my channel for regular
updates if you want to see even more
from me i also have an instagram channel
with even more content my instagram
handle is firm learning as well and i
also have an email list there's a sign
up link to that in the video description
as well i now want to take a moment to
thank all the members of this channel
firm learning thank you so much thank
you for your support without you all of
this would not be possible and if you
want to become a member as well and also
benefit from some member only perks
there is a join button next to the
subscribe button below if you hit it you
get all the details what it means what
all your benefits are and what you need
to do so thank you so much for your time
very much appreciate it looking forward
to next week's video as
every week i will release a new video
next saturday so until then have a good
weekend and bye bye